welcome to the Macmillan report I'm
Marilyn Wilkes your host and our guest
is Margaret Peters an assistant
professor of political science at Yale
University her research focuses broadly
on international political economy with
a special focus on the politics of
migration her work has appeared in
international organization world
politics and international interactions
she teaches classes on international
political economy and migration today we
talk with Professor Peters about her
recent world politics article entitled
open trade closed borders immigration in
the era of globalization
welcome professor Peters thank you so
much for having me let's speak in with
an overview of your article tell us
about it right so this article looks at
immigration policy in many different
countries over the last 200 years so
going back into the 19th century and
what we see during that time period is
we see that the 19th century was a
period of a fair amount of openness
towards immigration that's when you
think about you know all those people
coming from Europe over to the United
States are moving to other parts of the
new world and there was also a fair
amount of openness within Europe itself
what we see today as you can see and
like the recent migrant crisis in Europe
and other places is a lot more
restrictions on migration and then there
were in the past so this article looks
at you know why that is and examines
this by contrasting it to trade policy
whereby we see sort of the opposite and
trade policy you know trade is very open
today but in the past it was much more
restricted I see ok and what led you to
write the article I actually started on
this project back in graduate school
when I was a little second-year graduate
student and I just was looking at
immigration policies of interest because
it was something that was fairly under
studied in political science at the time
and found this sort of interesting
correlation that countries that had more
restricted trade policies seem to have
more open immigration policy and
vice-versa so countries that had more
open trade policy seemed to have more
restricted immigration policy and I sort
of started to wonder why why this was
the case and was there a relationship
between the two mm-hmm okay and your
your we'll talk about let's talk about
the research and and how you did your
methodology and it's kind of unique
where you've you've used data that
really hasn't been tapped before correct
so what I did for the project because
there wasn't really any data on
immigration policies over those that
long of a time period or really that was
publicly available to use I created my
own indicee of immigration policy for
these 19 different countries so they
include countries in the new world so US
Canada Australia New Zealand that we
typically think about when we think
about immigration it also includes
countries in Europe which are thought to
be sort of more newer countries of
immigration and then some of these
countries that in the global South that
get a lot of immigration like the
countries in the Persian Gulf so Saudi
Arabia and Kuwait and places like
Singapore so what I did is I collected a
huge amount of data over many years
looking at the laws that these countries
had passed on immigration and then what
I did some graduate assistants and
undergraduate assistant research
researchers I then coded this data in a
bunch of different ways thinking about
how do we think about immigration policy
and coded it Wow
it sounds like a huge undertaking so why
is it important to look at immigration
in an era of globalization well I think
you know a we're in an era of
globalization now and it's also just
this really interesting question when we
think about globalization we think about
the amount of openness there is towards
trade towards the flow of capital and
then when we look at migration there's
many more restrictions on it than there
is on these other flows and so if we
think about you know globalizing the
world and integrating the world and you
know having this one large world economy
it's sort of interesting that we don't
allow the same flows of people that we
do of goods or of money mm-hmm so has
immigration and trade policy been used
over time yeah so that's what I find in
the article is that when Trey
it's relatively more restricted you get
more open immigration policy and
vice-versa so the reason I think that
this is going on is it's going through
the actions of firms so when trade is
relatively restricted firms basically
don't find as much competition from
overseas because they've have trade
barriers that help them produce at home
and a lot of the countries that I look
at that are targets of immigration this
means that these industries like
textiles or toys or other low-skilled
Industries expand and so the firms then
lobby for more workers because they're
expanding industries there's not enough
labor and so they lobby the government
for creative numbers of workers and for
Greater immigration once trade opens a
lot of those low skill firms close so
we've seen this you know in here and say
the textile sector here in the United
States we don't really you know cheap
t-shirts we get them from China now
versus once upon a time they were
manufactured here in the United States
and as that happens as those firms
clothes they no longer need the same
number of workers and so they're not
even some of those firms aren't even
here to lobby for open immigration any
longer and other firms can use the
workers that those companies laid off
and so you just see many fewer
low-skilled jobs in the country much
many fewer firms that use that kind of
labor and because of that they just
don't they're just don't exist to lobby
on immigration any longer which allows
policy makers who are facing a lot of
constraints on immigration face a lot of
groups that don't really like
immigration to restrict it to make those
groups happy without making business
interests relatively unhappy mm-hmm so
how does trade policy actually affect
immigration policy then so it's through
this firm lobbying is what I argue is
that because you see the shrinking of
the low-skilled labor intensive sectors
in these countries so again if you think
about sectors that used to use a lot of
immigrant labor here in the United
States like since we're not far from the
main old textile mills and Lowell
Massachusetts and other places like that
that used a huge amount of immigrant
labor in the 19th century when those
industries are relatively productive
they then Lobby to
help keep immigration open whereas once
we saw a greater globalization and
greater openness to trade after World
War two and those tariff barriers came
down we've seen all those textile it
firms move out of the United States move
to try it I moved to Bangladesh move to
areas with cheaper labor and because
they don't exist any longer they're not
here to lobby the government for more
open immigration right right
so what do you conclude in the article
um so I conclude a couple different
things you know first of all it makes
this I mean this argument that this
could affect other areas besides
immigration policy so we could think
about this in the same way with maybe
environmental policy so as globalization
has allowed firms to move or their
production overseas or have been
affected by other firms from other
countries we've seen the dirtier
production move offshore and so we have
relatively cleaner firms here in the
United States and so that might mean
that it's easier to pass environmental
regulation here at home because the
dirty firms have just moved overseas or
don't exist it does mean that maybe it's
harder to pass global legislation on an
environmental policy but it could affect
environmental policy same thing with
labor policy and other social policies
it also means that unfortunately for
those who would like you know to do
comprehensive immigration reform here in
the United States who would like to have
more open immigration in Europe - maybe
deal with the refugee crisis that
they're having right now that because
you don't have the same level of
business support for immigration it
means that you don't have the same
coalition that you once did for open
immigration and because we think
businesses we tend to think that they're
relatively powerful and have ways you
know they lobby a lot they provide a lot
of campaign contributions and that sort
of thing it means that because there's
not that powerful group it means that
any those forces of anti-immigration
have relatively more power so you've
seen this most recently with the way
comprehensive immigration reform has
died again in the Senate and isn't even
being taken up in the House of
Representatives because there's no real
Pro immigration Lobby pushing for it
or not to the same extent and so
anti-immigration forces have relatively
more power so it just means that we're
probably going to see more restrictions
on immigration rather than more openness
right makes sense well thanks very much
for being here today and sharing some of
your work thank you for having me for
more information about Professor Peters
and her research please visit our
website at Yale edu McMillan report be
sure to join us again for another
episode of the McMillan report made
possible through funding from the
Whitney and Betty McMillan Center for
International and area studies at Yale
you